so I'm gonna be talking very quickly
here about treatment this is to give you
an overview before you actually start
working with children and again I hope
one of the things and we'll have a
chance to have a little bit of a
discussion and a week or so once people
have gone out is to get a sense of just
the tremendous variability and I hope
you get it this will make more sense
when she actually worked with some of
the children adolescents and young
adults to get a sense of just the
tremendous range both within the child
and between children so I want to say a
little bit about history of
interventions understand what may be
some changes actually in for the
positive and outcome with intervention
I'm gonna say a little bit about the
kinds of programs that are used and some
of the new strategies resources and
challenges if you go back to look
historically remember Connor described
autism in the 1940s 1943 intervention
programs really started the 1950s
including literally here I mean here
with the child studies in the early 50s
the first models of intervention were
so-called psychodynamic models treatment
models that revolved around presumably
fixing up some defect in the
parent-child relationship which was
thought to somehow cause autism the bad
part of this was it blame parents for
causing their kids troubles and we know
that's really not true probably a
minority of students with autism in
particular probably about 20% actually
went to school it was quite possible for
parents to arrive at school with a very
disabled child and to be told we can't
possibly take care of your child and the
parents might then say well what are we
supposed to do and the school might say
put them in a residential treatment
place and there were in fact places here
in Connecticut several state schools for
the mentally [ __ ] n'cole Emily
[ __ ] and children went there and
they stayed there and one of the things
that we've actually learned about living
in institutional settings is it helps
you learn to live in institutional
settings and so that's where the
children tended to stay the big
watershed in this country came in 1975
with public law 94-142 which mandated
for every child in this country starting
at age three education as a right
schools could no longer refuse to
educate
student's big difference I mean there
are other important laws and again if
you read in the book you'll read about
the Disabilities Act the ADA a that this
public law 94-142 really hard to change
and for the first time we're starting to
see children get intervention now I do
want to emphasize and people should have
seen on line there's a bibliography
including an annotated bibliography
there's a nice chapter for anybody who's
really interested in this by a woman
named Pat Helen who's in England who
does an overview of all the outcome
studies up through nine through 2005 and
she talks about some of the problems
interpreting the outcome studies and
there are some issues there differences
in methods we've changed the ways we
diagnose autism so there's some
complications that being said in general
the trim looks like it's been towards
better outcome I'm going to show you
some slides in a second to say there's
better adult outcome those of you
working in Chapel Haven this is a new
population in some ways which is great
people who are on the verge of being
able to make it independently go to
college live independently that's
wonderful news we have more children
with autism who have languished I just
taught you some spectrum but the more
classical autism or children with autism
can talk they also seem to be doing
better overall in terms of their IQ and
outcome now there are some issues
interpreting this research and I'm
presented with some words of caution and
especially when we talk about normal or
good outcome or what sometimes parents
will say oh my child is cured my
experience having seen thousands upon
thousands literally somewhere probably
between six and ten thousand children on
the autism spectrum I have met a handful
that if I met them I would say cheese
and I didn't realize it had something
wrong with them
a handful it's time to say it doesn't
happen it does most the time when you
see a child who's done very well some
form of social oddity remains and again
you can decide what what normal is you
can have a big debate about that but if
you mean living independently in self
sufficient I'll settle for that that's
great again there's the problems
interpreting all the research the early
confusion autism and schizophrenia
people didn't know who was being studied
we've changed the criteria over time
we've also changed intervention
practices so we have this public law
94-142 the let's call the IDE a
back to talk about when we talk about
mandates for services better detection
when I first got into this business in
1980 I came here to work the man named
Donald Cohen people didn't know what the
word autism meant if they said why did
you go to yell interested in children
with autism I said oh we need more
artistic children people thought I meant
the childhood artist so it's a very
different time and their issues in terms
of definitions and quantifying treatment
that being said I want to show you some
things about outcome and I'm gonna use
again this is quick and dirty but it's
effective good fair and poor outcome
good means you live in pretty much by
yourself fair means you need some
support and poor means you really need
pretty much 24/7 care so more
institutional kinds of settings and here
we go here's some of the first outcome
studies and I'm cherry-picking from Pat
Helens chapter from 1956 to 1974 here's
the date of the study and you can see
the percent of good fair and poor and
you can see poor outcome 65 70 percent
of people as adults are ending up in
very structured residential type
settings and here 1989 to 2003 and keep
in mind this is a complicated business
because we're changing our criteria
we're changing our interventions we're
doing all kinds of stuff we're mandating
services but look at the number of good
well it's up to the number of poor it's
come up and there's good reason to think
that this is a real thing it's a
complicated business but it seems to be
a real thing and this is great in terms
of what we can tell parents now about
what may happen to their child we think
probably we're doing better because of
earlier diagnosis we also know started
to think about very young children and
it's a real interesting challenge and
dr. Clinton and some other people are
gonna be talking about this there's
gonna have a whole talk on infants with
autism we do think that there are
important variables both in terms of
child and program we're understanding
more about what some of this is about
I'm going to try to illustrate that this
is a very simple but effective model for
thinking about what is going on in terms
of intervention autism is a disorder
that has a negative impact on
development when dr. klahn shows you
some of the eye-tracking work one of the
take-home messages is and the social
affective realm children with autism
may get perhaps 10% of the information
the rest of you are getting the ongoing
transaction they're getting a fraction
of what's going on when you think about
going into a first grade classroom where
you're expected to sit in a seat pay
attention to a teacher focus on what she
wants you to focus on that's a pretty
sophisticated load of information but
you're expecting a kid to take on board
so you can see for a child with autism
for whom the light switch or the light
fixtures or the sound of the of the air
conditioner or the blinds or the
mechanics of the slides that might be
much more compelling than me sitting up
here talking whereas all of you or
alternating your attention between what
I'm saying you're looking at the slide
you're going back and forth and back and
forth seamlessly it's a much easier job
for you than if you're polled the clock
on the wall of the light switch or the
or the ceiling so autism is a disorder
that has a negative impact on
development by causing trouble in terms
of information processing on the other
hand development happens shoulder with
autism change over time they grow and
develop so here is the summary this is
what we want to do in terms of
intervention we want to try to minimize
as much as we can the negative impact
that autism may have on learning and we
want to maximize the effect that we can
you know push in terms of normal
developmental processes and so that's an
in that she'll in a sense if you get
that you've got in the lecture I want to
say a little bit about terms because
we're going to talk a little bit about
the kinds of treatments there are
different kinds of programs and I'm
going to show you a summary in just a
second center based programs you take
your child to a center like then Haven
school home based programs somebody may
come into the home and help the mother
or father work with a child in the home
they may be programs in the public
schools we also have some states that
have statewide programs North Carolina
one of the first Delaware statewide
programs so there's a whole continuum of
services there are also some age related
issues in the United States and again
we'll talk more about this when we talk
about mandates for intervention there's
a separate system for children under
three schools are mandated to start
services app three so that age three is
a big dividing line also you'll hear
about different kinds of methods applied
behavior
aba behavioral methods tend to
predominate but they're not the only
kinds of treatment approaches things
like discrete trial pivotal response and
we gonna have a whole lecture and
behavioral intervention other approaches
use more developmental methods
developmental method might be for
example the child comes into the
classroom and the teachers agenda for
the day is they're going to learn about
let's say colors red and green they're
gonna sit and work on red and green
versus yellow and blue and whatever
let's say that and if you're a
behavioural person you might focus very
much on that a developmental person on
the other hand if the child may come in
having seen a red firetruck I may be
saying fire truck you might reorient
your whole lesson around fire trucks and
transportation and teach colors in that
regard
so again and these approaches are not
necessarily incompatible and many
approaches combine aspects of both
so-called eclectic programs and as you
heard we need to move from having an
evaluation to having an intervention
plan the intervention plan that we're
gonna talk more about later in the
semester is the IEP it's an
individualized educational plan for that
individual student and there's a lots of
ways this can get screwed up you can see
everything I think it was Buddha who
said if you only live long enough and
stayed in one place you can see
everything and it's true you can see one
of the kids who have wonderful plans and
the plan and practice is dreadful and
the vice versa
that's not usually the case I've seen
plans that were way too short I've seen
one plan that was a hundred pages
single-spaced I said when the world did
this so that you can see everything but
again to know there's a lot of potential
for gaps between getting the assessment
of doing intervention this is probably
the most important book to know about if
you're interested in terms of
intervention programs it's called
educating children with autism so the
National Research Council the National
Research Council got a group of talking
heads together of whom I was one and
they put together a report on our
intervention programs for juncture of
autism effective that's a question and
the answer was yes and so this report
summarizes all the programs in the
country and again it's in that chapter
in the book I'm going to show you a
slide a second that looks at some of
these programs it looks at all the
programs in the country that have some
data to show that they work and this is
the focus is on preschool young
school-age children
they note that many commonalities in a
few areas of difference between these
programs they also mentioned that not
every child gets better although as a
group it looks like with earlier
diagnosis kids are doing better and
better it's interesting these programs
all have some degree of university
affiliation which is not necessarily
surprising which that's where research
gets done in this country let me also
say that in summary this is a very funny
number because we're talking about very
different programs some school-based
center base and home based about on
average in a funny kind of a way it's a
funny number about 25 hours a week
year-round seems to make a difference
again the kinds of things that you look
at in terms of intervention programs
they should be planned and intensive
they use curricula developed for
children with autism they're
interdisciplinary because again the
child's going to have many different
needs occupational therapy needs sensory
needs speech and language days
behavioral needs may be medical issues
teachers have to have experience
training families are important to this
and Weyer family is important because
the generalization when dr. Cesana has
mentioned the problem with adaptive
behavior we literally have a young man
who's a math genius who solves equations
in his head all the time he is a
favorite kind of equation what could the
big dolls I don't get cheeseburger and
change and why is that because he could
do the math the cheeseburgers 99 cents
he gives two dollars you get a penny but
they'll be a young lady behind
McDonald's counter in her perky
McDonald's uniform and she will be
before he can get out cheeseburger
please he/she will say to him something
like would you like to try our chicken
fajitas special and he doesn't know what
to do because he's not going to enjoy a
chicken fajitas special he's gonna in
for a cheeseburger and maybe they've run
out of cheeseburgers or maybe if he buys
that chicken feed a special she'll be
his girlfriend and he would love to have
a girlfriend and so he just collapses
the nice thing about family involvement
is they help kids learn to generalize
skills so it's not just learned in
isolation the tendency to kind of learn
with blinders on is a real danger in
autism having child's really engaged is
essential looking at behavioral issues
and thinking especially about the
behaviors that both facilitate and
interfere with learning
and finally thinking about transitions
transitions of all kinds from junior
high to high school from preschool to
school-age from high school to adult
college vocational all these transitions
transitions are hard for people in the
autism spectrum and transitions in
school program are especially hard this
and again this is directly taken out of
the book but this is a summary of those
ten programs it's - the first five and
you can see here the name of the program
the mean agent entry of the hours per
week the usual kind of method the
approach they take in terms of teaching
and again the rest of the programs and
again this is there's exact table on
page 122 you can see various different
approaches and a combination of
approaches so early intervention seems
to be very important having planned
intensive intervention teaching specific
skills having kids really involved at
least for younger children unbalanced
about 25 hours a week seems to be the
important thing the kinds of things that
the program's work on are very similar
social skills communication play
remember this is a younger cohort we're
talking about for this report play
skills are important play is fast play
is social play it's got a call a lot of
cognitive shifting back and forth you
know I've got a cup with a couple can be
a bath that it could be a rocket ship it
could be a ray gun and it's the same cup
and you can see how confusing that would
be for a person with autism no that's
cup well that's whatever we choose it to
be it's very fast-paced organizational
issues and learning to learn this is
related to the behavioral problem if
you're focused and paying attention if
you can share a focus with the adult
you're going to have a chance to have
the adult conveyed to you some
information if you're scattered and
disorganized it's going to be a problem
and then finally that generalization
piece and again we want to typically as
we move into public school settings
think about what can we do to help the
child in the public school setting and
learn so recognizing how complicated
environments are difficult having a
balance between small group teaching
which is more intensively focused and
bigger settings paying attention to the
classroom environment don't for example
set the child always looking at the
window and watch all this stuff going on
with the child towards the front where
the teacher can keep an eye thinking
modifications for the environment if the
child has trouble marking out in the
floor this is your area this is you stay
within this area having cottonwood
consistency having flexibility and
having good school home communication
all-important social skills are
different approaches to teaching social
skills especially with preschool
children there's a very nice body of
work showing exposure to typical peers
with a little bit of preparation on the
part of the typical peer can have
tremendous payoffs in terms of teaching
social skills there are some good
curricula there talked about and that
the book things like the stay playing
and talk with your buddy it's not a very
complicated direction you know I want
you to play with stay with Jimmy today I
want you to play with him I want you to
talk with him for recess
you know kids could get that and again
but it means a little bit of preparation
to have tremendous payoff and there's
probably the most extensive body of work
in terms of social skills intervention
has been done with preschoolers as kids
get older there are some more challenges
often as kids get older we move away a
little bit from peers and talking about
more social skills groups often they'll
be a combination of an adult who's
leading the group and kids in the group
sometimes including normal peers typical
peers sometimes not as people get really
older adolescents and adults
unfortunately there are social skills
typically they're left in the dust
compare the typical peers so remember as
dr. Donna showed you that slide of the
12 year olds
we've got verbal IQs them around 12
years but there's social skills around
two years that's gonna be a real
challenge having them with other 12 year
olds method it's impossible but it's
often for that group that you have adult
instruction an adult instruction can be
very helpful throughout the lifespan
things like what you do and don't talk
to ladies about right those terms that
there's a long list of things you don't
talk to ladies about right well that's
important to know and you know for some
kids riding it down having a list of I
do not talk to ladies about certain body
parts we have one young man whose thing
was he used to he likes ladies and he
would admire their breasts than he would
comfortably so that's a nice set of
breasts you have and we've learned he's
learned with help say you have nice
longus now his parents don't what that
means but it's very adaptive but doesn't
get him into trouble
so again this it's interesting it's a
problem most of the research has been
done with younger children unfortunately
there are more and more programs of
social skills intervention and we'll
talk more about them again they vary a
lot but mostly with adults were talking
in adolescents we're talking about adult
mediated teaching if those are you
working at Chapel Haven they'll have a
lot of examples of this language of
communication is one of the things that
predicts outcome and autism having some
language by age five is a good good sign
we now think that probably about 75% of
preschoolers with autism can develop
useful speech that number used to be 50%
so it's again another indicator things
are going going on augmentative
communication approaches we're gonna
have a whole lecture on communication
augmentative is using other kinds of age
visual things photographs those of you
have been Haven you may see a whole
schedule for the child in pictures again
if you have trouble of language but if
you can understand the pictures that can
help you sequence you can even do things
you can have the schedule in the fridge
and the parents at home you can turn the
pictures over as the child finishes so
he can add or she can have a sense of
what's happened what's happening in the
future what's happened in the past
there's that whole technology this will
talk to some what about later on manual
sign would be another example that's
manual signing there was tremendous this
would be like the deaf for example the
problem with manual signing although is
is tremendous interest and it's so
useful for some children the trouble is
it's also fast-paced and it's transient
the beauty of the static visual thing is
you can go back to Egypt and see some of
the things written and the hieroglyphs
of the pyramids right same thing as
2,000 years ago
whereas the manual sign moves right
along so the visual strategies were
important we'll have a chance to talk
about that it sometimes is worrisome for
parents they say oh if you're using
visuals that means my child will never
talk or will never be able to talk in
fact we think if anything that there's
probably good potential anything that'll
help the child learn to communicate will
help the child talk and again this can
take the form of communication with
computers very simple things with
pictures there's a whole range of things
that you can put into play there are
some differences in terms of the ways
programs teach so the applied behavior
analysis
there's a whole technology we're gonna
talk about in terms of Behavioral
Interventions they're more developmental
approaches are the kinds of things that
we need to work on also in kind of real
life skills articulation and porosity
we'll talk a little about this later on
with RIA Paul catheters was mentioning
the difficulties with prosody I was
giving an example of the man who talks
in a very loud monotonic voice that's a
problem and that's the only voice you
got most of us probably have a thousand
voices I have two dogs they talk
differently the two dogs dead middle II
one of them is deaf which was a
challenge but when you think of it you
know you have hundreds if not thousands
of voices right so the gift we can try
to do with more able people with autism
is teach them three soft medium and loud
and which ones those where so church is
a show-off soft voice recess can be your
loud voice school classroom can be your
medium voice so there are lot of
practical things we'll talk with read
about speech pathology lots of things
that we can actually do conversational
skills what you can and can't talk about
how you have to give the person to turn
how you have to help them pay attention
to what the good nonverbal cues are the
person's turned and walking away they
probably are not having a conversation
with you right what are the things you
can't talk about they give no endless
examples if you work with more able
children they have wonderful examples
did I tell you about the kid who talked
to me about John Kerry so we had a child
who came in to see us for an evaluation
his mother was in the news business and
he looked at me and said it looked like
John Kerry but you're too fat well it's
that kind of thing that she was
definitely winning points with most
people so it's that kind of thing that
we need to work on mainstreaming the
presumption under the law as children
should be mainstream there should be
with typical children as much as
possible it's what the lawyers call a
rebuttable presumption which means you
can show it doesn't work you don't have
to there's a whole interesting
discussion about mainstreaming some
people wanting to advocate it as a
matter of right everybody has a right to
be mainstreamed you have to mainstream
some people say well you know let's
let's pick our setting the most common
problems with mainstreaming or people
pick settings in mainstreaming
where they have
the child with the least amount of adult
supervision so the three worst places to
mainstream are also the three most
common recess cafeteria and gym our kids
often do better being mainstream for the
more academic things and then put into
special places get their special
services in those less structured times
play skills we talked about again
there's a whole body of work looking at
teaching play and leisure skills this
becomes very important because it's also
a foundation for having social
interaction skills we're going to have a
whole set of talks later on in the
semester including one for Michael
powers about behavioral issues you have
some a vision of what you want as well
as what you don't want and that's
important as you can see oh this is bad
hand flapping you know body rocking and
stereotyped movements but there won't
even put in this place and so you have
to look at both and again there's a
wonderful technology on this this has
made a tremendous difference for
children especially children who really
need this kind of more intensive
behavioral work organizational skills
and this comes for the more able as well
as the less able child lists organize
your schedules software assistive
devices having something like an iPhone
or you know something you can have you
can call up you can see what's coming
next that can be great there's some
wonderful new apps actually for the
iPhone that have been developed for kids
with autism fantastic thinking about
software thinking about even for
functioning kids
simple assistive devices so two quick
examples we have one young man I'm gonna
say probably the fourth grade he had to
do a paper on Egypt this was a more able
kid with an Asperger's his thing is he
gets a thousand facts on Egypt they
can't write a paper all I got is a
thousand facts
so I told his father to go to PowerPoint
to have four slides the first slide is
Egypt history by Joe Blow not the kid's
name the next the title is Egypt at the
time of the Pharaohs the next egypt the
time of muhammad the next egypt today
then the child goes put put some of the
factoids in along with a few of the
pictures and then you click on outline
so you've gone from a visual to a
written and then
fill in the blanks we got a paper so
sort of simple things like that
for example of daily life shopping
shopping is a real problem we have a
lady who actually lives in my town in
Brantford who worked with our speech
pathologist she has a six-year-old boy
with autism he's very disorganized and
he's a handful and he goes to the
grocery store the speech pathologist and
the mother put together a visual
shopping list for this boy so it's got a
picture it's gonna he's gonna clipboard
and he's gonna set up pictures and it's
organized aisle by aisle sequentially in
the store and he's pushing a cart this
turns out to be a very sophisticated
behavioral thing because if he's pushing
the cart he can't get into trouble and
he's looking out for spaghetti sauce
because that's his favorite thing to do
was to eat spaghetti and so he's looking
for you know cans of spaghetti sauce
there's two cans and he gets them
crosses them off puts them in the cart
this is a nonverbal boy he's going on
he's getting this spaghetti goes on he
gets the whole business he goes to the
the line he checks out he goes home he
has a rest
and he cooks spaghetti he has all index
card with a recipe 50 cards to cook
spaghetti in the first one he's got a
picture of him eating spaghetti turn the
page on a little key chains with
sequential get the pot here's get the
pot here's the pot next page water in
the pot water in the pot pot of the
stove and again he can now cook it's for
him it's been very functional he can
shop and he can cook and that's great
and this much more than he could have
done otherwise adaptive skills we've
talked about the difficulty with
learning things in generalization our
kids often to learn like they've got
blinders on and you'll come up with this
we'll have some examples I'm sure as we
talk about this occupational physical
therapy can be very helpful in terms of
dealing with some of the sensory issues
the sensory issues and autism are
interesting they're very striking and
you'll see some children for example a
little something that the shirt will
bother them they'll just write them
crazy or some sound will bother them one
of the problems is when we've looked the
sensory issues although they certainly
are seen in autism they can be very
important in terms of dealing with them
when it's not so clear that they're the
kind of primary thing they may really
fallout from some of the social
vulnerabilities
that's not to say there aren't important
one of the problems has been often in
terms of dealing with some of the
sensory issues and sensitivities there's
probably less in this area of a good
solid research based in some of the
other areas but there are some
interventions and there's more and more
that people are starting to look at
thinking about gross and fine motor
problems kids with Asperger's the more
able kids who are very verbal but
socially disabled often have significant
motor problems this causes horrible
trouble when they get to the third grade
that need to write cursive and I've had
some interesting discussions with
schools over the years and there's ways
around this one of them is a laptop I
mean I could write something down for
you you wouldn't be able to decipher it
I wouldn't be able to cipher in five
minutes on the other hand I've written a
couple of books how can I do that laptop
so teaching kids to use things like
computers keyboards it sometimes causes
trouble because I mean I had one teacher
yell at me for giving the kid a crutch a
crap check watch I said yeah you know if
you didn't have a leg and I gave you a
question that would be a good thing it's
not a bad thing to give a person a
crutch if they need it but again you
have to be aware that for some people
these motor things can be really quite
dramatic sometimes and especially for
the younger children especially with
classical autism eating and feeding
issues its interestingly it's not so
much nursing issues it's when the solid
foods are introduced they'll be profound
likes and dislikes and it drives people
as parents especially the mothers crazy
and there's again some ways we can think
about working around dealing with that
speech pathologist could be helpful the
occupational physical therapist could be
helpful sometimes changing the texture
or the temperature of the food I've had
kids that would never eat mashed
potatoes if their life depended on it
but you make those mashed potatoes cold
put a little vanilla and some chocolate
sprinkles on top that's perfectly fine
so the interesting areas of sensitivity
and vulnerability if you were to take
and in fact there's a whole table in the
book won't we know an autism about
troubles and then how would you deal
with the troubles so if you've got
problems in an organization what would
you do you would be stepwise you'd be
consistent you would use routines you
would use visual aids you would give
plenty of time
if you have attentional problems what
would you do you would isolate the
relevant information set the environment
up to help the kid focus on what's most
important support the child's attention
in any way you can if you have trouble
of sequencing what would you do you
would give visual cues have
predictability and consistency kids with
autism tend to learn things in whole
chunks in some funny way this is
exemplified by their tendency to echo so
the child learns a whole phrase and it
stands for something it can be very
idiosyncratic and very unusual so how
can we help kids with echoing well and
the sort of tendency learn things in
chunk generalized by going across
settings helping the kid learn to break
things down in fact one of the positive
things for kids who only echo when we
start to see them break up their echoing
what's called mitigative echoing so it
breaks up a little bit that's a sign for
us the child is starting to learn the
individual words as opposed to the whole
chunk if you have visual learning style
what would you do use visual supports
limit verbal language keep language
short and simple one of the most common
problems you'll see this more probably
event Haven a little less at Chapel
another may be at both often when kids
are starting to have behavioral troubles
our natural tendency is to get to be
polite and polite is fine in most
contexts but often when we get polite
our language gets very much
sophisticated we start to use the
subjunctive remember the subjunctive
would you could you might you Jimmy
might you feel better than you know
wrong way to go Jimmy stop Jimmy do this
Jimmy can write and it's in a common
problem that we we tended to forget the
visual learning style in the attempt to
be polite we end up actually doing the
child a disservice because they have
trouble attending and lastly time and
temporal sequences visual support
concrete extractions adequate time
expectations outcome and feedback if I
were to give one of you a little cloth
rag and say could you clean that table
and you would be don't clean the table
you'd be done you look at me person with
autism might keep cleaning
cleaning and cleaning and cleaning and
why is that there's not a starting a
finish line so what would you do you
would adopt a strategic as a former
president would say you would start at
one corner and he worked to the bottom
what's stopping top left and work until
you get to the bottom right and you were
all done that would be a very effective
strategy because they would then have a
sequence that they could use trouble
understanding social cues you have to
turn yourself into a life insurance or a
car salesman you want to be enthusiastic
make it big make it bold right settled
know sellable be lost so exaggerated
keep things slow keep getting explicit
teaching and again we'll have chances to
talk once you've had a chance to go out
and work with some of the children will
have a chance to talk about what your
experience has been explicit explicit
explicit issues in mainstreaming we've
talked about this in terms of it's a
rebuttable presumption looking at peers
especially if they have some training
can be fantastically helpful and I
mentioned the three worst places to
mainstream the developmental approaches
look at how kids typically learn things
and that's a starting off point kids
with autism spectrum disorders sometimes
violate this I have one young man who's
down a very high-functioning man he's
actually written his autobiography but
when he was literally here at the Child
Study Center years ago in the nursery
school he didn't talk until he was four
and then he talked in full sentences he
skipped out single word the phrase stage
he started talking in full sentences
about an event that had happened the
year before that's not a typical pattern
developmentally so even though we're
prepared developmentally for kids to
follow sequences we have to know that
sometimes they violate them as much as
we can we want to pay attention to the
child's preferences and motivations and
we also want to pay attention to the
learning environment having an
environment that's very complicated
distracting for the child is not going
to be so helpful the more able kids
these are the very bright kids that
sometimes other people say oh no he
can't have autism or autism spectrum
he's too bright he's too verbal there's
tremendous variability in their
presentation one of the worst things
that happens is the kids can get labeled
as having behaved
problems and there's a whole link lingo
on this SCMS cd/dvd this means bad boys
social-emotional analogous and social
emotionally disturbed behavior disturbed
emotionally disturbed so they take a kid
who's socially clueless and put him in a
class with kids who are really bad boys
and then literally all hell breaks loose
I mean I've had the experience of having
a kid
six-year-old with Asperger's go into a
class quote unquote bad boys he's there
for five minutes the child says hey
Jimmy see that red box go ahead and pull
that red box see what happens and he
will he's clueless very quickly we're
going to talk a little bit about
Asperger's well I'm a chance to talk
more about this you've heard a little
bit from dr. Seuss honest we want to use
verbal stretchy juries verbal strategies
are actually helpful being very explicit
teaching things explicitly how come
you're feeling not how how do you know
how you're feeling if you're feeling
depressed how does that feel feeling
anxious how does that feel
making things explicit often these are
children have blow ups but they're they
haven't paid attention to all the steps
that lead up to the blow ups and those
of you at Chapel Haven will have a
chance to talk about this again we can
teach with kids with Asperger's verbal
scripts oh I have to remember I cannot
talk to people about deep fat fryers
unless I've given them a chance to talk
first or whatever it is but again kids
with Asperger's because they have this
verbal ability they can use these steps
and they can practice in their head
teaching explicit rules teaching things
like self correction am I talking too
much is this more than you want to know
about deep fat fryers would you like a
turn now all these are kind of sort of
stilted mechanisms but at least they get
the child feedback academic curriculum
and we're moving towards the end we
don't want to lose sight of the big
picture we want to emphasize the child's
strengths my usual joke is it's easy to
make the kid feel bad what we want to do
is help him feel good about something so
we want to think about ways that we can
actually use the child's special
interest whenever we can this comes up
especially with kids with Asperger's and
I think my next slide shows an example
of that yes so this is a young man who's
headed in Hurston snakes all his life
this is a kid with Asperger's the first
time I met him across the hall he
actually had seen our colleague Whitney
Marans
it's featured with Aldous and he had
talked to her about the dreaded puff
adder of England because she's from
England and then he saw my colleague ami
Klin is from Brazil and he talked to him
about the dreaded giant anaconda and
then I walked into the room and his
first comment was thank God at last an
American and then he talked to me about
the dreaded pygmy rattlesnake of upstate
northwestern Connecticut right so he's
got a thing about snakes so this kid
comes to the seventh grade in his little
town in upstate Connecticut and he's got
a write a thing on the Battle of
Gettysburg and there are rules he's got
to have a picture of the general he's
got to have a map he's gonna have
something about the battle and so the
teacher the mother and I were having
this whole discussion about this problem
and the teachers at oh if we could only
bring snakes into the Battle of
Gettysburg I said oh what a fantastic
idea so this was part of his poster
which I mocked up and he's got you know
robert e lee and there's where robert e
lee is he was the picture of the battle
there's the map and here of course is
mr. dawn piscivores the dreaded water
moccasin which is what he's really
interested in but he's learned a lot
about the battle even the context with
the snakes so when you can find ways to
do this it can be very adaptive it can
send them to be a real challenge well
when you can make it work it works very
well so again we want to have especially
for the child who's more cognitively
able kids with Asperger's but also with
autism sometimes people forget that the
speech pathologist and they somebody's
got such a wonderful vocabulary yes but
you can't carry on a conversation and
that's something again for those of you
at Chapel Haven who will have a chance
to talk about because it'll be a very
interesting experience people will be
talking at you but not with you and
again I think having one of the simplest
things that schools can do is having a
safe address for the child having
somebody that when the going gets tough
child can raise his hand and say I need
a pass to go see mr. Bob and off he goes
to see mr. Bob he has to come right back
it can't be a getting out of something
but the beauty of that is it disrupts
the problem behavior before it starts it
helps the kid be more reflective it gets
an adult involved who can go back to say
to the teacher hey how come Jimmy was
having trouble today we're Lou and it's
a very cost effective intervention and
again we'll have a chance to talk about
that over time
as we're getting back to the very very
end things that you can do and we'll
have a chance to talk about this working
on conversations what you can and can't
talk about how do you modulate your
voice I have some people will say things
like am i modulating enough but again
the fact that they're paying attention
is a plus encouraging self-monitoring
you can use video audio tape you can
work on these things now one of the
problems is we do a better job of
teaching kids about responding
initiating is really hard and one of the
things you will discover it especially
well actually both in both context how
kids come up and approach you can be
very idiosyncratic and one-sided and
it's really hard to intervene them that
at that at that level but again we'll
have a chance to talk about that and
finally for the more able kids keep in
mind that what seems like maladaptive
behavior and it may be very maladaptive
but it has to be understood in context
and the question is why is the child
acting this way one of my great examples
and I'll end on on this I think very
shortly there's a child from another
town upstate Connecticut who was good
with Asperger Suri's verbal but he's
motorically challenged and the town's
done a great job of getting services for
this child he's got an adaptive PE
teachers a wonderful lady and she's got
three or four kids in the class one day
she is sick it's a small district and so
who they get him to cover her class the
football coach because he's that do
anything in the morning right she got
this big guy lumbers in and doesn't know
much about little kids and they're
supposed to run the 50-yard dash or some
silly dash and the idea is they have a
stopwatch around their neck and they're
supposed to you know push a button and
run for the other and then stop and call
out their time to coach well this poor
kid who's it's he's almost of he's just
come Bobby late anyway it's a new person
somewhat scary person he's give him all
these instructions and you know this
coordination business has a bit of a
problem so he starts to running stops
because he's forgot to push the button
and so he stops that he's trying to
explain to the coach what's going on in
the coach to something that and even in
retrospect the coach himself said was a
mistake the coach says hey dummy why'd
you stop really helpful right so the kid
takes off the watch breaks it on the
ground the coach was really upset hauls
him off the prints
those office because No Child Left
Behind we got to kick him out of school
he's broken school properly I explained
in the class geez you know you're lucky
if I were the kid I would have hit you I
said you should have praised the kid and
so we had this whole discussion and it
was interesting because the he got it
and he understood what the troubles were
that he wasn't accommodating kid with
special needs but it's that kind of
thing that causes trouble and the more
you work with this population
aware of the tremendous potential
because most of us will generalize from
one setting to another here that can be
a real real real real challenge and
finally vocational issues thinking about
how do you work on getting a job
teaching grooming we had one young man
who wanted a job because he loves sports
he knew all about sports we arranged for
him to interview with a somebody from a
local paper to be a sports fact checker
and so we got the guy the reporter and
this kid together and the kid talked
about you know he knows everything
Michael Jordan's best your lowest stats
at the end you know the kid left the
room we said the reporter hey what do
you think of courses I've never seen
anybody who knew so much about sports
facts it's a shame he doesn't want the
job so how could you think that he never
once looked at me so we've learned that
one of the things we do is we teach
people at the beginning at the end
somewhere in the middle you got to make
eye contact so again it sounds kind of
dorky but it's it's actually very
effective so you have to work on all
these things well how much chance to
talk and for those of you especially a
Chapel Haven with more and more kids
going to college you know which is
fantastic there are other challenges you
may not appreciate it but the ability to
go to college is where mark pull you're
out there you're on your own you're
negotiating with your peers you're
negotiating with professors you and all
this stuff and for our many of our kids
it's a real challenge because
academically they can do it but it's all
this other stuff that goes along and
that's one of the beauties of a place
like Chapel Haven and family involvement
this is where we stop again we have to
have families involved the families are
there when we've come and gone the
family will be there for the long haul
of family are going to be involved
including parents and siblings and we'll
have a chance to talk over the course
the semester about that and we'll have
Allison singer well
come and talk about her spec her
perspective as a family member